louisville burns after officers aren't
charged in the death of brianna taylor
trump refuses to stay hand over power
after the election and anthony fauci
gets testy with rand paul over coveted
measures i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them
at expressvpn.com slash ben quick
reminder we have a backstage
scheduled for september 29th for the
first presidential debate yes we will be
hanging around
and watching that bleep show a debate
between the swedish chef and chewbacca
for all the marbles
5 45 pm pacific time 8 45 pm eastern
time become a subscriber for special
privileges
during our backstage over at
dailywire.com we're gonna get to all the
news
in just one moment first let us talk
about the fact
that you could be saving a lot of money
on your cell phone bill like a lot of
money
on your cell phone bill think about all
the money that you are automatically
giving to that cell phone company for
things like unlimited data
are you using unlimited data you
probably aren't in fact if you are using
less than two gigs of data you are
really really overpaying for that
telephone bill
right now the average person is saving
400 a year on their wireless bill just
by switching over to pure puretalk usa
puretalk will give you the exact same
coverage
same tower same bars but it'll cost you
half no contract no excessive fees
right now enjoy unlimited talk text two
gigs of data all for just 20 bucks a
month
the average person is saving 400 bucks a
year on their wireless bill so
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
250 bucks off any iphone including the
new iphone se
again that is pound two five zero say
keyword ben shapiro that's pure talk usa
simply smarter wireless there is no
reason for you to spend too much on your
cell phone bill when you get the same
coverage
for less money like why are you just
flushing money down the toilet instead
grab that mobile phone dial pounds at
250 say ben
shapiro when you do you save 250 bucks
off any iphone including that new
iphone se go check out puretalk usa
today okay so last night another
city set on fire set on fire after
there is an indictment that comes down
for one police officer in the briana
taylor shooting
the indictment really was not because of
the shooting at brianna taylor
it was because this officer filed fired
wildly and hit an apartment wall and so
the idea was that he had misused his
firearm
now as i've been talking about for a
while see here on this show
we like to give you the facts of
scenarios so you know what's coming
probably
a month ago i went through the timeline
of the brianna taylor
killing and i talked about the fact that
while it was a tragedy there was no law
breaking and it would be nearly
impossible to make a case against any of
the officers
in briana taylor's killing that's
specifically because they had a
well-predicated warrant
a no-knock warrant for her apartment the
reason being that she was caught on tape
talking with her ex-boyfriend about
being involved in drug trafficking
apparently
about using her apartment as some sort
of pass-through where he could pick up
his mail
and the cops had a no-knock warrant on
her apartment when they arrived they
apparently knocked despite the no knock
warrant
and then her boyfriend got out of bed
and
he didn't answer the door he
he just apparently as he was going down
to the door he didn't know who
it was even though they said they were
the police he didn't hear them say they
were the police and then they bust
through the door
at which point he has a gun on him and
he fires to the police
he hits one of the police officers they
fire back at him and in the process of
firing back at him they kill brianna
taylor who was
behind him okay that is a tragedy and
it's a horrible tragedy
it does not mean a crime was committed
this was a
well-predicated no-knock warrant even in
order to prove there was a crime that
was committed what you would have to
prove is that
not only was the warrant bad the cops
knew the warrant was bad and they
decided to serve it anyway
and then they decided that they were
going to act in violent me in violent
measures
with a bad warrant in order to hurt
brianna taylor and you can't prove any
of those elements
lawyers have been saying this for a long
time on the brianna taylor case and not
just me i'm talking about
people on the left who have studied this
case recognized that there was almost no
chance of bringing a prosecution
in this case again because the timeline
just does not lend itself
to a prosecution in this case because
the cops didn't do anything criminal
here just cause something bad happens
doesn't mean that the bad thing that
happens involves violent law breaking
bad things happen
every day that does not mean that the
person who was involved in the bad thing
is to blame when you are talking about
criminal liability
here's a brief timeline of what actually
happened in the brianna taylor case and
see
here on the show we like to talk about
the facts of cases because it explains
whether people's reactions are justified
i understand that in the media
everybody's reaction to any situation is
justified just so long as it cuts
against the narrative that america is
good
if america is bad your reaction is
always justified it doesn't matter
if brianna taylor's officers actually
that if the killers in the brianna
taylor case
accidental killers in this case if those
people got off
because they should get off that doesn't
matter it is instead indicative of
deeper american cruelty
and racism it doesn't matter if michael
brown was shot justifiably
it does not matter if jacob blake was
shot justifiably it does not matter if
rashad brooks was shot justifiably
none of that matters the only thing that
matters to people who are in the media
apparently
is the narrative that america is bad
filled with racist cops and every single
law enforcement scenario that does not
end with a cop going to jail is more
evidence that america's cops are
systemically racist and that america
itself
is shot through with 1619 style
slavery-based racism
this is the take of the media we don't
do that here because it turns out that
you
usually want to link facts with the
underlying narrative
facts don't care about your narrative
you might say the facts are what the
facts are well in this particular case
the facts demonstrate that the officers
or the officers
clearly should not have found themselves
in the position of criminal liability
with regard to the death of brianna
taylor
here is what the the louisville courier
journal
had to say about the timeline on
december 30th the police executed three
search warrants in the russell
neighborhood seizing several guns and
narcotics among the six people
subsequently arrested was jamarcus
glover brianna taylor's ex-boyfriend
on january second using a surveillance
camera police saw a white chevy impala
pull up in front of 2424 elliott avenue
which is one of the houses hit with a
search warrant a few days earlier glover
got out of the passenger side of the car
registered to taylor glover is seen
driving to taylor's springfield drive
apartment and walking inside on january
16th
after a brief stay police saw glover
leave with a suspected u.s postal
service package
and then drive to a house on west
muhammad ali boulevard which was also
hit with the search warrant on december
30th
on february 14th after an officer towed
his car from west muhammad ali boulevard
glover attempted to file a complaint
against the officer
the phone number he gave on the
complaint was registered to taylor
on march 12th the warrants were set in
motion as of midday
detective joshua jones an officer in the
play space investigations unit of the
criminal
interdiction division requested five no
knock search warrants from circuit judge
mary shaw
for an ongoing narcotics investigation
okay the warrants were predicated
on a 39-page document demonstrating
links between glover
and taylor including prison visits and
prison phone calls
between taylor and glover in which they
discussed
the the movements of packages for
example at 12 25 pm shaw
signed off as the judge on the
affidavits for the first two warrants
for houses at 20 20 24 24 and 24 25
elliott avenue
and then a few minutes later signed off
on 24 26 l8 avenue and then
another house at 2605 west muhammad ali
boulevard
and then a few minutes after that the
judge signed off on the search of
taylor's apartment which was 10
10 miles away in south louisville why
well because in the affidavit
the officer wrote that glover's car had
made frequent trips to taylor's
springfield's drive apartment
that glover walked directly into
taylor's apartment on january 16th a u.s
postal inspector verified that glover
did receive packages at taylor's
apartment
remember glover was running a drug trade
taylor's car had been seen in front of
the elite avenue on different occasions
at approximately 9 p.m taylor and her
boyfriend kenneth walker this is not her
ex-boyfriend
jamarcus glover was her was her
ex-boyfriend her new boyfriend was
kenneth walker who by the way was
friends with with glover apparently
taylor and her boyfriend kenneth walker
get home from dinner at texas roadhouse
and giving a friend's kids rides across
town it was taylor's first night off
after a few consecutive days with
12-hour shifts as an er technician
they climbed in bed put on a movie at
approximately 10 p.m police officers
were briefed on the entry plan
for taylor's apartment just before
midnight about 45 minutes before serving
the warrant
mattingly said he drove by taylor's
apartment while another officer
detective
mike campbell had an eye on the house
the only thing campbell saw while
watching taylor's apartment according to
mattingly was the light on the tv in the
bedroom
police thought taylor would be home
alone inside the apartment taylor had
fallen asleep
watching the movie freedom writers and
walker said he was starting to doze off
at 12 40 am officers were in place
outside taylor's apartment and began to
knock on the door remember they didn't
have to knock on the door because it was
a no-knock warrant
after a few knocks mattingly said they
began to identify themselves as police
there were there's at least one witness
who said they identified as police there
were other witnesses who apparently said
that they
didn't hear them identify as police they
had no legal obligations to identify
themselves as police
you may not like no knock warrants but
this is a legal procedure in louisville
the knocking startled taylor and walker
out of bed
they began yelling out so originally we
were told by the way that brianna taylor
was completely asleep
she was not that is only relevant in so
far as they did not just shoot a
sleeping woman who's lying in bed she
apparently was behind him while she was
awake the knocking startled taylor and
walker out of bed they began yelling out
asking who was there
according to walker and they didn't hear
a response supposedly after about a
minute and hearing no response from
inside police used a battering ram
to knock in the front door so this is
where the discrepancies begin between
walker's account and the police's
account that's a walker says he's
yelling who's there and the police say
we didn't hear him so maybe they didn't
hear him because the door so thick or
maybe they didn't yell out because he
was getting a gun
after a minute and hearing no response
from inside police used a battering ram
to knock in the front door
walker had grabbed his gun as both he
and taylor pulled on clothes and went to
answer the door
they left the bedroom they hadn't made
it down the hallway before the door
started coming off his hinges
at 12 42 a.m neighbors in the saint
anthony garden apartments called 9-1-1
to report gunshots
walker said he fired one shot at a war
as a warning aimed at the ground but
that isn't true because he actually shot
one of the police officers in the leg
officers on the scene dispatched called
dispatch to report that an officer had
been shot at 12 43
taylor was struck in the return fire by
police at 12 47 a.m walker himself
called 9-1-1 and said somebody kicked in
the door and shot my girlfriend at 12 48
that was taylor's official
time of death 10 miles away police were
simultaneously raiding glover's
apartment that was her ex-boyfriend
and three of his associates and they had
him in custody they seized drugs and
guns and cash
from those elliot avenue properties the
fifth warrant on west muhammad ali
boulevard was not executed
police arrested walker after commanding
him to walk backwards as he left the
apartment
at 1 10 a.m police told dispatch there
was a woman inside of the apartment
at 1 46 a.m ems left taylor's apartment
complex
inside of taylor's apartment they found
shell casings and bullets but no drugs
and no cash although they did find mail
for glover who again was the target of
the narcotics investigation
and the warrants were predicated on the
idea that taylor had been working
with glover and receiving mail on his
behalf okay so
here's the bottom line this is a tragedy
is that
a law violation by the legal officers
who are tasked with breaking up a drug
ring
is that a legal violation by them not do
you like no knock warrants that's not
the question
i think that there's a case you made
against no knock warrants particularly
in low-level drug cases
in the case is fairly good actually but
does that mean that the police officers
who were fired upon and returned fire
and killed brianna taylor in the
crossfire that those
officers are guilty of murder or
manslaughter
remember the officers broke through the
door on a legally predicated warrant and
they were shot at
once they are shot at they are going to
return fire by the way
the the person who shot at them walker
originally he was charged
with attempting to shoot a police
officer and then they dropped the
charges
after it became clear the taylor was
dead there was going to be a lot of
blowback we still don't know the full
circumstances
surrounding what exactly happened in
that apartment what we do know is that
if you fire on police officers they're
going to fire back at you
so whether he thought that he was firing
at just a rando who was breaking down
his door
or whether he thought he was firing at
the police tragedy
not crime okay and this is exactly the
finding of the
louisville ag of the kentucky ag
nonetheless the city burns because the
narrative does not matter the narrative
the narrative is the only thing that
matters rather the facts do not matter
whatsoever the facts don't matter one
iota to people who wish to burn things
and pretend
that every fact pattern is indicative of
deeper american cruelty and bigotry
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
who is black
he is also a republican he spoke at the
rnc will recall he uh he announced
the lack of charges yesterday there was
only one charge filed against an officer
and that was for
essentially recklessly using his weapon
because he fired uh
in the wrong direction and hit an
apartment wall and he said in the in the
middle of a statement that he met with
brianna taylor's family
which again he should do this is a
tragedy but it does not mean it was a
crime
here was the kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron
to have to sit in that room and provide
the
information uh to miss palmer and two
other members
of the taylor family it's been a
difficult day this is a difficult day
for everyone standing up here this is a
difficult day for
those here that have to report this and
it's a very difficult day
for louisville all of the commonwealth
all of the country
i recognize that okay so
obviously this is not somebody who is
lacking in compassion which is the only
measure by the way
for democrats when they when they
measure virtue are you somebody who
i mean we've been told this about joe
biden empathy is where it's at well
cameron obviously is an empathetic
person
who's deeply disturbed by the situation
that does not change the state of the
law
and this was the point that cameron was
making throughout yesterday which is we
have a legal process in place
just because something bad and tragic
happened doesn't mean that i am allowed
to charge someone and put them in jail
for a legal violation here was daniel
cameron saying they were justified in
the use of force
our investigation showed and the grand
jury agreed
that mattingly and cosgrove were
justified in the return
of deadly fire after having been fired
upon
by kenneth walker let me state that
again
according to kentucky law the use of
force by mattingly
and cosgrove was justified to protect
themselves
this justification bars us from pursuing
criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death okay now
remember the police department in
louisville has already settled with the
taylor family for some 12 million
dollars so civil liability
did attach they didn't admit civil
liability but they settled this thing
out of court
so there's a difference between a
criminal charge and a civil charge right
a civil case means that you are suing in
tort okay and the level
of the the level of legal surety that
you require in order to get a civil
judgment is far less than the level of
legal
surety you require in order to get a
criminal conviction criminal conviction
is beyond a reasonable doubt
when it comes to a civil case it could
be preponderance of the evidence for
example meaning like does the majority
of the evidence
show the officers shouldn't have done
what they did and
police departments routinely settle out
because they don't wish to
brave a jury that may not like them very
much in these cases
in any case cameron then called out the
activist he said listen you might
want to look at the facts of the case
instead of listening to the activists
nobody's doing that of course
there will be celebrities influencers
and activists who having never lived in
kentucky
would try to tell us how to feel
suggesting they
understand the facts of this case that
they know our community
and the commonwealth better than we do
but they don't let's not give in to
their attempts to influence
our thinking or capture our emotions
at the end of the day it is up to us
okay and he is right about all of this
by the way again jamarcus glover who's
the person who is involved with brianna
taylor is a bad dude okay she was
involved with him
she was changing her life as sort of
what the story was that she'd broken up
with him a month previous
and she had moved on and that was a good
thing obviously
but according to the police records his
actions
basically led to all of this i mean he
was using her
house in order to receive packages in
his drug ring among other things
he also made her rent a car where he
then left a dead body apparently
and then because of using her apartment
he ended up leading the police to her
dorm there's a point that thomas
chatterton williams has been making
the facts of the case suggest that the
outrage against the police is misplaced
the outrage really should be against her
ex-boyfriend
and against no knock warrants generally
if you don't like no knock warrants that
is fine but instead
everybody has decided because again we
don't care about the facts in this day
and age
everybody has basically decided that the
only thing that matters in the end
is that the police are systemically
racist and america is evil
so joe biden put out a statement from
his basement where by the way
joe biden has not emerged for days joe
biden has been doing this thing where he
he calls a lid
okay i didn't know what that was until
yesterday apparently calling a lid
is where you just say i'm not coming out
of the basement the entire day so the
media can go away
he said that at 9 36 a.m eastern time
today he's been doing it every single
day
if this is a well man why exactly is it
he has called a lid i believe 40
of the days of his campaign in the last
several weeks
why okay in any case he puts out a
statement here is his statement
in the wake of brianna taylor's tragic
death we mourn her mother we mourn
with her mother family and community and
asks ourselves whether justice could be
equally applied in america
see it's indicative of the evils of
american due process that we actually
use due process in this case
and we looked through the law and that a
black ag who has sympathy for brianna
taylor's family
used the law instead of his own personal
feelings to charge which by the way is
the way it's supposed to work
if you are a law enforcement officer if
you are an ag
if you are a district attorney you're
supposed to look to the law
you're not supposed to look to the mob
outside your window that is not justice
it is not justice to look to the mob
outside your window and then decide
based on what they want that you are
going to swivel the law
in order to achieve their purposes
that's not it's the opposite of justice
as mob rule cameron refused it joe biden
is calling for it
he says i know for so many people
today's decisions does not answer that
call for equal justice
a federal investigation remains ongoing
but we do not need to wait for the final
judgment of that investigation to do
more to deliver justice for brianna
we know what is necessary we need to
start by addressing the use of excessive
force
banning chokeholds and overhauling no
knock warrants
okay again this was not a case of use of
excessive force they were fired upon
there was no chokehold that was applied
in this particular case
and you can overhaul the no knock
warrants except that they knocked at the
door and identified themselves
apparently according to witness
testimony
the former vp then added blandly that
violence is not acceptable
and said protest should be peaceful
adding do not sully her memory or her
mother's by engaging in any violence
it's totally inappropriate for that to
happen except that you keep fostering
the notion that equal justice
is not possible in the united states
when you say okay so people outside
chanting no justice no peace
then you have joe biden saying you're
right there's no justice what do you
think is the natural consequence of the
statement no justice no peace when you
agree no justice
you can say yeah it would be nice if you
guys peacefully protest but you're out
there literally saying that we've never
done enough for equal justice and we
cannot do enough for equal justice
you can't back the narrative in the
absence of underlying facts
and yet that is exactly what joe biden
and the media and celebrity class have
done so the celebrities get very angry
and i know that when i am looking for an
excellent legal analysis of a given fact
pattern i go to viola davis
that's exactly where i go the oscar one
of villa davis she tweeted out
bull bleep decision black lives matter
cannot be said enough times
nobody's arguing that black lives don't
matter we're arguing as to whether legal
criminal liability attaches when you're
a cop when you knock on the door
announce yourself break in the door
because of no knock warrants and then
are fired upon and then returned fire
mandy moore she she tweeted out i don't
have the words
hashtag brianna taylor and her family
deserve justice
i mean this isn't about quote unquote
justice for brianna
this is about justice for the police
officers who are on trial right they're
the ones who are going to have to be
put through the justice system here one
of these officers is going to be charged
with again
misuse of his weapon justice for briana
taylor
would be presumably there are a couple
of types of justice one is like a cosmic
justice
okay the courts of earth are not granted
the ability
to grant some sort of cosmic justice all
they can do is follow the law as it
exists
and in civil court again the brianna
taylor family received 12 million
dollars in a settlement
from the louisville police department
kerry washington tweeted out daniel
cameron is on daniel
is on donald trump's shortlist as
replacement of rgb on the supreme court
the same man who decided to not charge
the officers responsible for killing
brianna taylor
vote oh so it's the cameron's the bad
guy guys
cameron is bad you see because daniel
cameron followed the law and we don't
want him to follow the law
we want daniel cameron to completely
ignore the law and simply try officers
for not violating the law
ava duvernay who is the the
documentarian propagandist
uh who makes these absurd overwrought
documentaries about how
american slavery never ended and such
she put out a
and who uh cheered on the the great
citizens of chaz chop while that
newly formed fascistic republic was
created
in the middle of seattle she tweeted out
god bless brianna's family and all who
knew and loved her her tragic death
compounded by the violence of silence
and inaction by the city she called home
is more than any of them should have to
endure what do you mean the violence of
silence and inaction
they went through a full-scale
investigation they paid her 12 million
her family 12 million dollars that
doesn't seem like violence and inaction
per se
the rapper comments read out to be a
negro in this country and to be
relatively conscious
is to be in a state of rage almost all
the time james baldwin hashtag brianna
taylor
okay again quoting james baldwin from
like the civil rights era
55 years later as you know a
millionaire famous black rapper
actor seems mildly inappropriate mia
pharaoh she tweeted out
so no one is responsible for killing
brianna taylor actually i mean if we're
going to parcel out responsibility there
are a few places to parcel out
responsibility for the killing of
brianna taylor number one is andre
marcus glover her ex-boyfriend
who roped her into a drug ring okay that
would be where i would put most of the
responsibility
and then there would be the boyfriend
for whom again it is not particularly
clear
why he was firing at the police officers
did he not know who they were
if he didn't know who they were that's
somewhat justifiable but at no point do
the police officers become responsible
for not returning fire when they are
fired upon
you can put on the the no knock warrant
that's fine but there's no criminal
liability attached to police officers
returning fire
doesn't work that way yvette nicole
brown tweeted out no officers charged in
the killing of brianna taylor we know
she's very serious because there are
lots of periods in that sense
it's no period officers period charge
period in period the period killing
period of period brianna taylor period
which is um not proper grammar
one was charged for endangering but not
killing her neighbors
make me want to holler and throw up both
my hands
the law is not a repository for your ire
or your feelings that is not how this
works
anthony rapp black lives matter
apparently he changed his name
officially
on twitter he tweeted out black lives
matter brianna taylor's life mattered
what has been announced in kentucky is
not even remotely in the realm of
anything that even begins to approach
true justice for her murder that is a
long run-on
sentence okay celebrities get mad okay
then over on espn jalen rose former nba
star he interrupted the middle of an nba
broadcast to simply shout that the cops
needed to be arrested like this is
literally in the middle of the nba
broadcast
an nba broadcast where you can see up
there in the rafters the hashtag united
in black
and then the black lives matter on the
court
is just um in case you didn't get it
sports are now just msnbc with various
forms of bouncing balls jalen rose the
announcer literally just shouts in the
middle of the broadcast that we need to
arrest the cops
thank you d.a jalen and you know d.a
rose i'm so glad that you're elected
attorney general of the state of of
kentucky so you could simply effectuate
the law as you see
i mean this is the exact opposite of
justice by the way justice typically
means
that you have to be held accountable for
the things that you do in terms of
criminal liability
not that we craft a crime to fit a
tragedy that's not how any of this works
here is jaylen rose losing it last night
in the middle of the broadcast
tyler heroes scored in double figures
every game this postseason he's been
putting in work for a young fella
but it'd also be a great day to arrest
the cops that murdered brianna taylor
um that literally this is during the
halftime report
he tyler hero's having a huge day also
do what i want you to do legal system
even if it's not really in compliance
with legal procedure
i i can't imagine why the ratings are
down i know that when i watch sports
what i desperately need is jalen rose's
criminal legal analysis
it's huge i really need to hear it
lebron james sounded off on it also of
course because lebron james is again one
of our great legal scholars
again i would like to see a lawyer like
an actual lawyer
explain where the criminal liability
lies here i have yet to hear
an actual qualified legal voice say that
these officers should have been
criminally charged
on any side of the op alleyway left
right center
it is nearly impossible to there were
articles going months back
quoting liberal professors at like the
university of kentucky talking about how
there were going to be no charges in
this case this is not unexpected this is
fully expected
it should have been expected we talked
about the facts of this case months ago
but you have to understand the media
fact pattern here the media pattern is
never discuss the facts of the case
instead say the name
don't look at any of the underlying
details and then just shout and then
just shout as loud as you can just
just shout as loud as you can about how
every tragedy
is a result of the american system it is
not that tragedy sometimes occurs in
life
through confusion through chaos through
bad action by third parties no it's
always the system the system is to blame
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that these
days it seems like um in a lot of major
cities violence is rising
and if you live in one of america's
major cities you can look around you can
see it
in your daily lives and now you're
starting to see that chaos is starting
to move
out into the suburbs if you're feeling
unsafe these days
if you're a law-abiding citizen now
would be a good time to think about
getting a firearm and more importantly
knowing how to use it being educated
about that firearm
this is why you should join up with the
the uscca
that's the us concealed carry
association right now you can make a
simple powerful journey to firearm and
self-defense confidence it's called the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide
from the united states concealed carry
association the uscca it is 100
free you will learn in this guide how to
detect attackers before they see you
how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun particularly if you have
kids and a whole lot more it's 164 pages
it comes with a bonus audio version so
you can listen whenever you want
it is really important to own a firearm
if you're a law-abiding citizen it's
even more important to know your legal
rights and
how to use that firearm just text ben to
and get instant access and a chance to
win a thousand bucks so you can buy a
gun to protect your family text ben
to 87 222 right now again text ben to
and now the reason i've been going
through the brianna taylor fact pattern
in in great detail here is that you know
how full of crap our members of the
media and celebrity class are
just absolutely full of crap so joy reid
who's awful
and given a show on msnbc despite the
fact that she has battled tweets that
would get anybody else canceled
but apparently somebody went back in
time and hacked her her blog back in
like 2003.
anyway she went on msnbc and she says
this this decision by daniel cameron
it's a black lives don't matter
ruling oh is it joy then you explain to
me how legal liability attaches to the
legal performance of a no knock raid
that ends with somebody shooting at the
cops and then returning fire and
accidentally hitting
a third party you explain that here was
joy reid saying it's a black lives don't
matter ruling again the narrative
overcomes the fact every time
this was a black lives don't matter
ruling because they said that her life
was irrelevant
that the life of her boyfriend who was
in the apartment with her
didn't matter that he attempting to
defend her was the crime
the potential crime was him trying to
defend his castle so the castle doctrine
is wiped away
when police bust into your home you
don't have the right to defend yourself
well actually that's not really true
considering that in this particular case
the guy who shot the police
was not tried right they released him
originally they charged him
and and you do not have the right to
resist arrest so it was unclear whether
he thought he was resisting arrest in
which case they could have charged him
with attempted murder of a police
officer or
whether he thought that he was firing on
somebody just randomly breaking into his
apartment
that's why they released him he didn't
end up in jail did he then joy reid
tweeted out damn this wasn't just a
black lives don't matter decision it was
an
only white lives matter decision my god
this country can't get out of the 1920s
can't it joy really can't it i've
noticed that you
are a black woman who has a show on a
major national network
a huge social media presence and you say
stuff like this routinely to the
seal-like
clapping of your fellow media members i
don't remember that happening in the
1920s when black people were literally
being shot in the streets of tulsa
oklahoma for the sin of being black
i don't remember this happening in the
1920s when black people
were literally prevented from voting by
white mobs
i don't remember this happening in the
1920s when there are full
legal regimes in place to prevent black
people from drinking at the same water
fountains as white people
do i read you idiot i mean seriously
this kind of stuff is just despicable
and it infuses so much of the left's
view on race in the country
what they'll do is they'll find
something terrible that happened a
hundred years ago and they'll be like
you know what nothing's changed
a lot of things have changed a lot of
things like for example
in the 1920s let's say that the police
had shot a
black woman in the middle of a drug raid
do you think it would have been a black
attorney general of the state
deciding whether or not to charge what
do you think do you think that
the attorney general of the state of
kentucky in 1920 would have been black
i'm gonna go no on that one probably but
don't worry nothing has changed
nothing's here don lemon another idiot
on cnn
he decried the lack of indictments legal
expert don lemon who can't even explain
what
a constitutional amendment is he's so
dumb that chris cuomo even looks at him
and is like dude you're a here's
don lemon talking to wolf blitzer again
the meeting the the amount of wattage in
prime time on cnn
might be able to toast a piece of bread
lightly if properly channeled here is
don lemon
legal genius it's just another instance
as someone who works in the news media
of there being
i would say now three different justice
systems one
systems in this country one for police
officers one for americans of color and
one for white americans
that's how folks will see it play out
but really i think that
the real tragedy i know the real tragedy
is for brianna taylor's
family i mean how i feel it's you know
it's inconsequential to how
that family uh must be feeling right now
okay when he says things like you know
people are gonna see this people are
gonna see this like
there's one system of justice for black
people and one system of justice for
white people
why are people gonna feel that way don
could it be because you didn't report
the facts of the case
could it be because you don't give two
dams about the facts of the case could
it be because you don't even bother with
the legal analysis
i mean meanwhile msnbc again repository
of all virtue they have al sharpton
a two-time quasi-riot insider
and falsifier of actual criminal
activity
by tawanna braulie and blaming police
and da's
for a false rape that never happened
this guy they're bringing on msnbc to
talk about race-based cases it's just
wonderful
our media are fermenting racial unrest
in the country and they are doing it
with with a broad sense of of their own
virtue here is
al sharpton how this guy remains on tv
after being the kind of piece of crap he
is is beyond me here is al sharpton i
think it's grossly insufficient
it does not deal with the fact that the
light
of brianna taylor was taken it does not
address
uh being a a victim
of being killed the value of her life
is not at all addressed in these charges
you could get endangerment if you shot
in the air at nothing
you took a woman's life in returning
fire from a person who was firing upon
you during a no-knock drug
drug bust what okay this was the media
the media are fomenting this stuff they
want this stuff the media want conflicts
whether they want conflict
on the level of what happens after the
election as we'll see or whether they
want conflicts when it comes to
race-based violence in the country msnbc
hosts a guy named jason johnson
and he literally says you cannot go
anywhere if you're black in america you
can't go anywhere for black in america
to be safe it's weird cause they're 43
million black americans
the number of unarmed black americans
who are shot by police every year
numbers under 20.
but apparently for black america you
literally can go nowhere anywhere to be
safe in america
amazing stuff from jason johnson
busted into my house right now and shot
me on the air
what daniel cameron basically told
america
is that that would be legal if they
thought that there was something wrong i
could be
shot in broad daylight on national
television
in my house because the cops can break
in and shoot whoever they want
if they're concerned no no okay just
stop this
that's that's fundamentally untrue that
is the greatest lie
the cops could not break down jason
johnson's door in the middle of a
broadcast and shoot him
you know what they would need to do if
that one if that were to happen god
forbid you know what have to happen
number one they would have to have a
no-knock drug warrant taken out with a
judge
two they would have to bust through the
door three jason johnson would have to
fire on them before they fired on him in
order for that to happen
they were returning fire so no they
can't do what jason johnson just said
and bust down my door if they think
something is wrong and then just shoot
me in cold blood
no they cannot do that they would go to
jail for that
okay but apparently again this is the
the media
fomenting the idea that black americans
are living under the boot of white
americans in the same way that black
americans were living
under the evils of white supremacy for
at least several centuries of america's
existence
msnbc christian clark repeating this
message it's over and over and over and
over again and then you wonder why
people are in the streets literally
firing
weapons of police officers which is what
happened in louisville last night this
all culminates last night
in in violent protests that break out
including the shooting of two
louisville police officers and then you
wonder why this happens you rev
people up to the pitch where you say
that black people literally cannot be
safe in america that any black person in
america including prominent commentators
on msnbc
can be shot and murdered at any moment
by white cops and then
you wonder how it is that violence
breaks out they know violence is gonna
break out and they do not give a damn
apparently
i don't know how else to interpret this
sort of irresponsible and insane
commentary
here's msnbc's kristen clarke explaining
that racism infuses
all policing all of it
there are those who say why are people
protesting why does the black lives
matter movement
exist and it exists because of moments
like this
when the system fails us as black people
it's an
incredibly disappointing day and a
reminder of the
tremendous work that must be done to
address the ways in which
racism infects every aspect of policing
the criminal justice system and our
lives
okay except that you offer no
prescription for removing racism from
any of these things because you know
full well this is not a system
of racism this is not racism okay this
is a tragedy
not all tragedies our crimes and not all
crimes have to do with racism
but in america for the left all
tragedies are crimes and all crimes are
indicative of an evil american system
the most insane comments of the day came
courtesy of cheryl dorsey another ms
msnbc is just a trash heap cheryl dorsey
on msnbc
saying that the attorney general of
kentucky daniel cameron because he's
black
he's particularly bad because he's
complicit in the system don't you see
he is he's a racist right because you're
either racist or you're anti-racist he's
not anti-racist
because he's in favor of the system and
therefore he's a racist here is cheryl
dorsey claiming
i am not kidding you this is her quote
that cameron is skin folk
not kin folk you see he's black but he's
not truly black because were he truly
black he apparently would have indicted
these officers without
any underlying legal predicate here's
sheryl dorsey
i find all of his remarks with regards
to this whole entire press conference
offensive and let me just speak to this
whole celebrity influencer thing
while they can't speak for kentuckians
let me say this is a black woman
he does not speak for black folks he's
skin folk but he is not kin folk
and so just like he thinks they can't
speak for kentucky
because he's up there with a black face
he does not speak for all of us this was
not a tragedy
this was a murder he should be ashamed
of himself it was not a murder
it is clear it was not a murder from all
of the underlying evidence
all of it but again that means that he
he's skin folk he's not kin folk right
he's not truly black
a truly black person would recognize how
deeply evil america is and that every
incident no matter what the underlying
fact pattern is indicative
of that religious view that america is
deeply evil and racist as we'll see
this results in an extraordinary amount
of bad behavior that is quickly
overlooked by the media
as well as a bunch of white liberal
prostration before the
slogan-yearing nonsense of the black
lives matter movement we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now is a very bad time to go to an auto
parts store in fact you know what never
is an excellent time to go to an auto
parts store
instead you should check out
rockauto.com i mean you go to the auto
parts store and you're asking them for a
part then they have to order it
online and then they up charge you they
might give you a different price based
on whether you're an expert or whether
you're newbie
you're never going to get any of that at
rockauto.com it comes directly to you
and they have excellent selection and
you can actually take the time to get
the right part
rockauto.com offweez offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based
on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much on the same
parts rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
right now
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com they're always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
again for the same parts they have
amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need check them out at
rockauto.com the internet makes
everything cheaper and better why
wouldn't you apply that to car parts go
check them out at rockauto.com
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about
so they know that we sent you okay we're
gonna get to the violence that broke out
last night in louisville and the media's
willingness to cover
for it we're also going to get to the
supreme court and the
very controversial trump comment about
whether he would hand over power if he
loses the election we'll get to that in
one second first
as part of our daily wire audience there
are a lot of different ways you can take
in
this magnificent podcast you can listen
on apple podcast or spotify or another
podcast app
you can also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com here's the bottom line we
are making our content available to you
anywhere you watch or listen
dailywire members can now enjoy our
shows on apple tv and roku so members
can enjoy all of the visual elements of
this podcast and our other shows on your
big screen either live or on demand find
the daily wire on apple tv or roku and
download today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com use code watch at checkout
to get 15
off your membership purchase this deal
is not gonna last long so act fast if
you want live shows on your big screen
plus that one of a kind highly coveted
leftist year's tumblr
uh again that is dailywire.com shapiro
to get 15 off
with codewatch download the daily wire
on your apple tv and roku today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so as the entire media predictably
avoids mentioning the facts of the
brianna taylor case in pursuit of a
narrative that america is deeply evil
and that daniel cameron is deeply evil
and donald trump is deeply evil
and the flag is deeply evil and you
should kneel for all of these things
and that you should go out in the
streets right and you should pro you
shouldn't get violent guys
against the system that has its boot on
your neck but you should definitely
protest
shockingly people both protest and also
get violent who could have predicted
such a thing except for anyone with a
functioning prefrontal cortex so
last night in new york city thousands of
people marching in new york city
i i will say i am deeply amused by the
fact that the media continue
to do this sort of mask-shaming
crowd-shaming thing
where trump holds rallies oh look at
that big crowds very bad
then giant crowds show up in order to
protest whatever the media liked that
day and egg on that day and they're like
oh no problem at all so here are
thousands of people in new york city who
are marching i mean they literally can't
go to work so it makes some sense
there's thousands of people in close
proximity to one another and people like
oh well they're wearing masks i mean
they're wearing masks
yeah if they were on the beach you
wouldn't be shouting that would you
you'd be talking about the evils of
rhonda santas
okay meanwhile over in louisville
people showed up on mass of course and
and decided to protest but they didn't
just show up
they had organized violent activity
planned
and there was tape yesterday circulating
in the middle of the day a u-haul
literally just shows up on the streets
of louisville
and people start unloading shields and
batons and all sorts of fun stuff
and this is black lives matter
protesters unloading signs that say
abolish the police with the anarchist
symbols antifa members who are wearing
all of their black
gear they're getting their shields
they're getting their signs
they're ready to go why look at that
look at that look at all that
spontaneous social justice action
popping up from a truck you just unload
the truck and hand this stuff off to
people
really really solid stuff meanwhile a
giant crowd confronted a police line
and all of this again is good in the
middle of a coveted pandemic the
pandemic doesn't exist anymore guys
you can't go to your job you can't visit
mom in a hospital but
you can definitely shout at a cop within
two feet of him there's a good stuff
happening in louisville yesterday
yeah you seen a lot of masks there how
about that a lot a lot of mess you
seeing right there no
no you're not you're seeing people
directly yelling at other people's faces
i like this guy with the tennis racket
it's like roger federer over here
probably on his off day
carrying clubs carrying batons good
times
lots of mask wearing just that's
probably fine
all of it's probably fine media have
anything to say about this of course
not okay meanwhile people were running
around carrying clubs cursing at police
officers
the police officers literally just
standing there and ignoring them now if
this were a fascist police force you
think they would be doing that you think
this sort of stuff happens in belarus i
don't think so
here are people literally walking
through police lines shouting at police
officers harassing police officers
really a nice group of people really
really nice stuff happening right here
very classy riders in the middle of the
day were targeting businesses as well so
that was excellent
people just running into business hey
look it was time to uh go and loot an
antique store
and some of us just need an antique guys
they're looting a place called it looks
like andrew gentile antiques
people literally just going and knocking
over chairs and i mean if you need an
ottoman
to protest brianna taylor's death you
need an ottoman gang
i mean these are these are important
moments
now we know that last night two police
officers were shot in louisville
according to reuters louisville on
thursday braced for a second night of
protest after two police officers were
shot during demonstrations
over a decision by a grand jury to bring
no direct charges against policemen in
the fatal shooting of briana taylor
the protest erupted in the kentucky city
on wednesday immediately after the state
a.g announced
none of the three white officers
involved in a deadly botched raid on
taylor's apartment would have to face
charges of causing the black woman's
death
one officer was indicted on charges of
endangering her neighbors because he
fired at a wall
civil rights activists decried the
outcome as a miscarriage of justice in
keeping with a nationwide pattern of
unwarranted police violence
against minorities the demonstration now
the headlines are just wonderful here
the demonstration that started
peacefully on wednesday night turned
violent after dark when two officers
were shot and wounded
police arrested 127 people
in louisville 127 people also
protests flared up in new york l.a
atlanta and seattle
in oregon in portland police once again
declared a ride on wednesday in the
unrest that followed the grand jury
decision
here is how reuters headlined this stuff
this is the reuters headline ready
demonstrations in louisville wore on
past nightfall in defiance of a 9pm
curfew and remained mostly peaceful
until several gunshots rang out in the
midst of a skirmish between protesters
and heavily armed police
oh is that several gunshots rang out you
see they just rang out randomly
and also it was mostly peaceful until
people shot cops
the media are actively downplaying
violence the media are actively covering
for violence they are saying that the
more rageful you are the more justified
is your
rage that is the argument that is being
made it's disgusting
it's wrong and it is undergirded by
another disgusting wrong idea which is
that america is brutally viciously
unalterably racist
and that every incident no matter the
fact pattern is indicative of that
racism
now the good news is that this makes
middle-aged white ladies feel real good
about themselves
there are some middle-aged white ladies
who feel really really good about
themselves for being able to declare
their dissociation from the rest of
evil white america apparently one of
these people is the
president of ohio university
of ohio state rather the ohio state
university her name is christina m
johnson
and she put out a statement after briana
taylor again remember this happened in
kentucky this is in ohio right this is
the ohio state university
here is president christina m johnson
explaining
we cannot accept this verdict we can't
accept it you see
because she's a woke white lady and as a
woke white middle-aged lady
who is speaking a foreign language
reading off the cue cards printed for
her by robin d'angelo and imbramax
kennedy
she is going to be anti-racist and to be
anti-racist means of course to tear down
the systems
so i guess that she's going to have to
take those diplomas off the wall she's
going to have to give up that office to
somebody black in the name of racial
justice
and she's going to have to abdicate her
position and make sure that all subjects
at ohio state university are advised to
teach
the social justice warrior nonsense that
kenny would love
here is here is the president of the
ohio state university participating in
the death of intellectualism
at the highest level we grieve the
tragic and senseless loss of brianna
taylor
a daughter a friend a niece
a loved one who is unarmed and asleep
the breakdown in the justice system
and the killings of unarmed black and
brown people in our country
has become all too familiar tragically
this isn't going to stop until we create
an anti-racist world
we must come together to draw strength
from each other
and advance our collective vision for a
better world
where we one day have justice for all
well you know why you read off those cue
cards the mao's struggle sessions have
begun we have to create an anti-racist
world an anti-racist world
okay so i very much look forward to the
federal investigation of ohio state
university for its complicity in
systemic races in the same way that
princeton is now being
investigated for racism since they
admitted they're complicit in systemic
racism here's the deal she doesn't
believe she's a racist
she doesn't she knows she's not a racist
because she isn't a racist but
she is a racist by ibrahmax kenny's
calculation because she is part of the
racist system you see
and it doesn't matter if the system has
done something racist with with regard
to brianna taylor
or not any any system that results
in an unequal outcome okay not that the
due process was given
and then the outcome was what it was it
results in an unequal outcome
that means the system is racist and so
you have to have performative wokeness
by a bunch of elite white people
talking about how they can regain the
moral high ground
simply by declaring themselves part of
the anti-racist movement now the thing
is
that they can never declare themselves
fully anti-racist ibrahim x kennedy has
said this clearly
he says you can never reach the level of
anti-racism you can try to cleanse those
racist thetans over and over and over
but
until you continue to pay the price
eventually you might be clear but that's
in the far future and
even then you're not really clear
because we can always point back to the
fact that you are complicit in your own
whiteness even if you are unconsciously
complicit in your own whiteness
at no point you have to allow for any
proof of your position if you're
ibrahmex candy
you don't have to offer a single iota of
data to back your position that
anti-racist training makes america less
racist
not one it is a religion it is a
religion
the media participate in this religious
practice it is a religious practice to
believe
that america is racist based on a case
in which a woman is shot
accidentally by police officers
returning fire in a no-knock raid okay
that is a religious position that that
is indicative
of 400 years of american racism
the only way that you can believe that
is if you have already come up with the
outcome and the outcome is unfalsifiable
and that is that is what is happening
right here now the good news is that we
can always count on our politicians
particularly those in the democratic
party to really focus in on the true
cause of the violence we're watching in
our major cities
i did find this amusing mayor ted so
there was another riot declared last
night in portland oregon
ted wheeler the worst mayor in america i
mean there's been heavy competition this
year we've got eric garcetti on that
list we've got bill de blasio on that
list we've got laurie lightfoot on that
list
we've got land kisha lance bottoms on
that list
mayor ted wheeler dude takes the cake i
mean we
he even beats the minneapolis mayor guy
mayor ted wheeler is just
a bleep show he tweeted out on september
26th agitators plan on coming to
portland to spread messages of hate and
racism
values we don't welcome here in portland
if you intend to come to our city our
home
to spread hate and provoke violence
don't now apparently this is directed
against the proud boys
it's fine to say to the proud boys we
don't like your values you're literally
every night
green lighting blm and antifa attacking
police officers
every night in your city for months on
end
yes clearly the problem is that some
right wingers are going to come into uh
portland
some some alt-righters are going to come
into portland that's clearly
the big problem mayor ted wheeler
amazing amazing stuff okay so that was
this is story of the day number one the
other controversy of the day in which
the media have been
promulgating and pushing the possibility
of violence is the story that president
trump is not going to leave peacefully
now
show of hands how many people truly
believe that the president
is not going to leave peacefully if he
loses the election okay
no hands up that's what i thought you're
all full of crap
just gonna put it out there you're all
full of crap none of you in the media
believe that trump won't leave
peacefully if he loses
if he loses he will be ushered out of
office and he'll be ushered out of
office
whether he likes it or not he is not
going to hole up in the oval office
al pacino style at the end of scarface
snorting lines and firing
guns through the door and shouting about
meet my little friend
like that's not what's gonna happen he's
just gonna leave that's all that's going
to happen we all know this
this is perfectly obvious donald trump
is a person who says a lot of crap
is it good crap no very often it's bad
crap and trump does not help himself
when he says bad and stupid crap in
response
to a bunch of questions that are bad and
stupid
but there's a notion that trump is going
to prevent his removal from the white
house by any available means
is a it's a leftist fantasy it is a wish
because they would like violence
they would okay they've been promoting
this for months now we've seen stor
the only people who game doubt the
possibility by the way of actually
involving themselves in some sort of
resistance with the use of the military
is john podesta he actually went through
the full exercise of
what happens if there's a divide between
the electoral college and the popular
vote again
and then they're a bunch of rogue
electors and then california decides to
break away from the federal government
they went through that actual exercise
we have seen leftists fantasizing about
the possibility of violence after the
election so as to justify their
preparation for violence after the
election
there's a long article in the atlantic
like a super long article
in the atlantic by barton gellman called
the election that could break america if
the vote is closed donald trump could
easily throw the election into chaos and
subvert the result
who will stop him and then he lays out a
bunch of
variations on the theme that maybe there
will be trump supporters who
create combat in the streets he says
suppose that caravans of trump
supporters adorned in second amendment
accessories
converge on big city polling places on
election day they have come they say to
investigate reports on social media a
voter fraud counter protesters arrive
fist fights break out shots are fired
voters flee or cannot reach the polls
then suppose
trump declares an emergency federal
personnel in battle address staged
nearby in advance
move-ins restore law and order and
secure the balloting amid ongoing
clashes they stay to monitor the canvas
they close the streets that lead to the
polls they take custody of uncounted
ballots in order to preserve evidence of
fraud
norm ornstein of american enterprise
institute says the president can't
cancel the election but what if he says
we're in an emergency and we're shutting
down this area for a period of time
because of the violence taking place
if you're in trump's camp and he listed
boundaries he said what i would expect
is you're not going to do
one or two of those things you'll do as
many as you can barton gilman says there
are variations of the nightmare
the venues of intervention could be post
offices the predicate could be a
putative intelligence report on forged
ballots sent from china
and then he admits this is speculation
of course but none of these scenarios is
far removed from things the president
has already done
or threatened to do what what has he
threatened to do
well he threatened to dispatch the
national guard to dc and sent dhs to
portland oregon
he said he might invoke the insurrection
act and deploy the us military in order
to protect life and property
the federal government has little basis
to intercede during elections but no one
familiar with a.g bill barr's view of
presidential power
should doubt he can find authority for
trump okay so basically this is just a
long
masturbatory fantasy by barton gellman
in the pages of the atlantic
talking about how trump is going to
steal the election
he's going to he's going to mess around
with the constitution in order to ensure
that he remains
in office now what is the evidence that
any of this is going to happen
first of all he says well there are
contingency plans like if x y and z
happens then maybe there will be an
attempt to invoke certain constitutional
principles
in order to prevent electors from voting
or whatever democrats have already
announced they have the same contingency
plans right john podesta gamed it out
already
and by the way worth noting hillary
clinton literally
said like a month ago that under no
circumstances should joe biden concede
the election under no circumstances
should he concede the election
so when we talk about discounting the
results of the election what do you
think will be more probable violence in
the streets of trump wins or violence in
the street if trump loses
i think everyone knows the answer to
this you and the media know the answer
to this too here was hillary clinton
just a few weeks ago saying that joe
biden should never concede the election
ever under any circumstances
they have a couple of scenarios that
they're looking uh
toward one is messing up absentee
balloting so that they then
get maybe a narrow advantage in the
electoral college
on election day joe biden should not
concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is gonna drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give an inch and if we are as
focused and relentless as the other side
is
this is amazing okay we're seeing
violence in the streets is it right-wing
violence that we're seeing in the
streets
we saw protests after the last election
was it right-wing were there lots of
protests after barack obama beat romney
i missed it
yeah oh wait no i didn't miss it it
didn't happen okay this is all
leftist wish casting this is all
projection it's all projection
it's just it's absurd and now
hilariously enough the democrats are
reversing themselves so a few weeks ago
it was voting in person's really bad
guys we can't vote in person because it
coveted super serious now
they realized they shot themselves in
the foot because number one voting in
person is not bad
they had a huge vote in wisconsin just a
few months back
lots of people showed up no covet
outbreak so you can't vote in person but
they were trying to claim
that trump had botched kovitz he
couldn't vote in person so everybody
should vote by mail
hoping that there would be an
overwhelming balloting advantage in the
mail-in ballots now they're realizing
oh wait a second a lot of people aren't
going to bother voting by mail and so
you're going to end up with a lot of
trump voters
who believe that covet has been
exaggerated by the media showing up to
the polls
and voting and our people aren't going
to show up so now they're reversing
themselves and they're saying every
democrat should show up to vote in
person
well isn't that weird what happened did
kova just wane did kobe just win
the electoral chaos that's being
fostered right now is not being fostered
by trump
it is not democrats have have put
forward these bizarre conspiracy
theories about how trump is going to
foil the election
by removing mailboxes which is just
absolute sheer bull crap
about how the post office doesn't have
enough money to process mail-in
balloting which of course is absolute
sheer nonsense
they've been complaining that trump is
going to somehow manipulate the systems
of government
in order to ensure that he never leaves
office sure it's speculation
sure there's no indicator that he's
actually doing any of this but you know
you know it could happen and that's why
we have to mobilize right now
and that's why we should never surrender
according to hillary clinton to the
rabid cheers of the msnbc recount crowd
which is my favorite part of that little
hillary clinton quote is the cutaway
shot
of the person asking her the question
literally raising her arms in triumph as
hillary says never concede the election
these are the same people who say that
stacey abrams is still governor of
georgia
okay stacey abrams lost by 50 000 votes
they never accepted the results of that
election okay so
does that alleviate the problem when
president trump says dumb stuff no it it
actually does not
so president trump was asked yesterday
about whether he would commit to a
peaceful transfer of power
now let's remember something about trump
if he has never thought about a question
he has a pattern of thought his pattern
of thought is well think about it i
haven't really decided yet you know
we'll have to see what happens he says
this about everything
you could ask him mr president do you
have any plan
to launch a rocket filled with
chihuahuas
to the moon to set up a space colony
well i haven't thought about that it
might be a good idea many people are
saying it's a very good idea
like you could literally say anything to
him mr president do you have a plan
to create a giant drill down to the
center of the earth and then harness the
heat of the earth's core
and use it for energy to power the grid
and trying to be like well that's you
know that's something i've never thought
of but maybe you know it's
many i have thought of it actually i
thought of it so much more than any
other human has thought of it
and it might be a good idea the experts
are looking into it we'll look into it
that's how he answers any question he
has not considered for more than 20
seconds
that is really right and this is why
when people ask him about like q anon
and he doesn't
know what the hell q anon is he'll be
like q and they seem like good people
they like me i mean like whatever i mean
all i see is that they like me that's
how like and then like well they they
say that they
that you're preventing cannibalism and
he's like well you know cannibalism
is bad do you like cannibalism i don't
like cannabis like this is trump
he is a font of babel okay he is not a
tower
he's not quite a tower of battle but
he's certainly a fountain of babel
right out of that mouth emerged many
things some of them are fully formed
thoughts many of them are not okay so
yesterday on the
after in the on the aftermath of this
this barton gelman idiotic piece in the
atlantic
speculating that trump is going to steal
the election and all of this trump has
asked
about committing to a peaceful transfer
of power and trump
who does not even compute the question
he
again people are going to say that i'm
defending trump's comments the comments
are egregious okay no president
should not say there should not be any
president who says anything other than
of course if i lose an election there
will be a peaceful transfer of power as
there has been in every presidential
election
since the beginning of the republic and
that is the clear and obvious answer it
doesn't make it any better
that trump is just spouting nonsense
babble here right he should have a clear
answer
but again am i going to take trump super
seriously on this stuff do i think that
trump
is now getting ready in the basement of
the white house tanks from the secret
service to
to defend the white house against the
encroachment of the incoming
inaugural committee no i don't and i
think that nobody in the media does
either and they know it
they know it they have crafted a
narrative out of whole cloth where trump
holds up in the white house snorting
coke and firing guns through the windows
and they're gonna stick by this
narrative and then they're gonna go to
trump to say whatever dumb thing he says
to pour gasoline on the stupid fire
and the stupid fire rages out of control
and nobody has an incentive to actually
just grab a damn fire extinguisher and
point out he's not gonna do any of this
crap we all know he's not gonna do any
of this crap anyway here's trump saying
a very dumb thing
will you commit to making sure that
there is a peaceful transferal of power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else
okay so the way that the question is
phrase is peaceful transition of power
right
are you going to get violent and trump
takes this as am i going to concede the
election in the same way that hillary
clinton took the question
am i going to concede the election or
should biden concede the election and
said no trump says no okay so the media
spin themselves up into a frenzy over
this
now again did trump say a dumb bad thing
here yes again no president should say
anything other than
of course if i lose the election and
it's legitimately held then i will
peacefully transfer power
that's always the obvious answer there's
no excuse for him to say anything else
also he says dumb crap all the time and
no one should take this seriously
because it's not serious it is not a
serious thing this is not a serious
answer from a particularly serious
person
end of story but the media spin
themselves into a frenzy because again
this is the narrative they want the
narrative they want
is that trump is a threat he's an
authorian authoritarian threat to the
republic now democrats are seriously
seriously talking all of the democratic
leadership is currently talking about
ending the filibuster
stacking the senate packing the court
they are talking
openly about measures they can take
post-election
to resist okay they are openly talking
about this stuff
and then they go to trump and they're
like and president trump what do you
think and then in his own inimitable
talk radio caller
commenter way they ask him like so will
you peacefully translate
i like you know if the ballots are legit
sure but if they're not then you know
what screw it
okay people very often suggest it's a
defense of trump
to say that you don't take him seriously
but what if i don't actually take him
that seriously when he says stupid crap
because
he says it all the time and if you do
then i don't know what's wrong with you
if you take him super seriously when he
says stuff like this
i don't know whether you're being
disingenuous or just moronic
chris hayes is being both i think so
here's chris hayes on msnbc saying trump
is plotting a coup
he's plotting a coup says chris hayes
if you're talking to a person and you
ask them to commit to behave
peacefully and they refuse their
threatening violence right
what the president is doing here is the
most explicit that he has been
about his plans for this election he's
plotting and open in public repeatedly
a coup to steal the election and hold on
to power again
it all sounds crazy to say it is what we
are seeing those are the plain facts as
assembled before us
it's not a behind the scenes type of
thing it's happening
in public in plain view okay so what is
the natural
consequence of this sort of talk the
natural consequence of this sort of talk
is that if trump would actually win
democrats are now going to think that he
could it
democrats are now going to think he sold
the election so they're incentivizing
violence they want
the battle in the streets they're
incentivizing this sort of stuff they've
been doing it for months
okay you can try to pin it on trump's
idiotic comment yesterday you can
but here is the reality for months they
have been claiming that republicans are
going to steal the election that orange
hitler
is going to just maintain power no
matter what they've been saying this
since 2015 right they asked him the same
question in 2015.
are you going to concede the election to
hillary clinton if you lose and he was
like no we'll have to see and then
they're like oh that's terrible then
they went and asked hillary and she's
like well i wouldn't concede either
pretty much and and they were like oh
well that's okay
okay this is projection the only people
who are going to be resisting the
results of an election are people on the
left we all know it
we all know that's the reality but the
left have to project
so they can then claim that it's legit
when they quote unquote resist
because they're resisting a coup all
right enough of this stupidity for now
we'll be back a little bit later today
with two additional hours of content
including commentary on anthony fauci's
dust-up
with senator rand paul so he and rand
paul had a bit of a dust up
where anthony fauci says some things
that were factually untrue uh and he
said him in pretty high-handed fashion
actually we'll get to that a little bit
later today but you have to be a
subscriber to check all of that out
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
democrats attack president trump for his
answer to their question over whether or
not he will peacefully transfer
power to joe biden then they proceed to
burn
a couple more american cities and
democratic governor gavin newsom
bans cars check it out on the michael
knowles show